>> CONGRATULATIONS, JA.
>> JA MORANT.
>> SO THAT DOES IT FOR THE
WESTERN CONFERENCE.
>> I'M EXCITED TO SEE HIM IN THE
ALL-STAR SETTING.
>> FRONT COURT, THE CAPTAIN WILL
COME FROM THE FRONT COURT.
>> OKAY.
>> THIS TO ME, THIS SHOULD BE --
>> CAN I ANNOUNCE IT?
>> I'M TELLING YOU WHO IT SHOULD
BE.
>> THE CAPTAIN LEADING VOTE
GETTER IN THE EAST.
KEVIN DURANT OF THE BROOKLYN
NETS.
LEADS THE LEAGUE IN SCORING WITH
29 A NIGHT, SIX ASSISTS, SHOOTS
52%.
>> HOW MANY?
>> 12th ALL-STAR APPEARANCE THIS
YEAR.
IN HIS 15th SEASON FOR THE
FOUR-TIME SCORING CHAMPION.
AND TWO-TIME HORSE CHAMPION.
KEVIN DURANT.
SO DOES THIS MATCH, OR DO YOU
WANT TO SAY?
>> ACTUALLY, I GOT CONFUSED.
I THOUGHT YOU WOULD STOP WITH
THE BACK COURT.
>> NO.
FRONT COURT.
>> I HAVE NO PROBLEM.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM.
KEVIN DURANT -- KEVIN IS LIKE,
THE ONLY PERSON ON THAT TEAM I
LIKE.
>> LET US CONTINUE.
>> I REALLY LIKE KEVIN DURANT.
>> WITH THE TWO OTHER -- FRONT
COURT STARTERS.
GIANNIS ANTETOKOUNMPO AND JOEL
EMBIID.
MVP.
>> YEAH.
OF COURSE.
THIS WAS PRETTY CLEAR CUT, I
THINK.
BACK COURT WITH THOSE THREE.
GIANNIS, SIXTH STRAIGHT ALL-STAR
APPEARANCE.
HE'S AVERAGING 29 INCHES.
FOURTH IN REBOUNDS WITH 11.
SHOOTS 53%.
HE'S HAD 19 30-POINT GAMES, FOUR
40-POINT GAMES AND THREE TRIPLE
DOUBLES.
AND JOEL EMBIID, FIFTH STRAIGHT
ALL-STAR SELECTION.
29 POINTS A GAME.
THAT'S NUMBER THREE.
REBOUNDS WITH 11.
21 GAMES OF 30 POINTS OR MORE.
SIX GAMES OF 40 PLUS, THE MOST
IN THE NBA.
>> HE'S THE MVP IN THE LEAGUE.
>> I'LL SAY IT NOW BY FAR.
>> BY FAR?
>> BY FAR.
LISTEN, NO DISRESPECT TO ALL
THESE GUYS, BUT THAT MAN RIGHT
THERE IS PLAYING BETTER
BASKETBALL THAN ANYBODY IN THE
WORLD.
>> I DON'T DISAGREE.
WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF
BASKETBALL TO GO.
BUT EVERY TIME I LOOK AT HIM AND
SAY HE'LL WIN IT EASILY, THAT
SAME NIGHT I'LL TURN ON IT AND
SEE JOKIC AND JA MORANT.
YEAH, HE MIGHT BE WINNING BUT IF
HE SLIPS UP IN THE SECOND HALF
OF THE SEASON, WE'VE NOT GONE
TOO FAR.
>> HE SCORED 30 PLUS IN 14 OF
HIS LAST 15 GAMES.
SHALL WE MOVE ON?
>> YES.
>> CHUCK THOUGHT IT WAS COMING
MOMENTS AGO.
THIS IS GOING TO BE INTERESTING.
>> WHAT IS MY FAVORITE CITY?
I GOT TWO FAVORITE CITIES.
TORONTO AND CHICAGO.
>> AND HERE ARE YOUR STARTERS IN
THE BACK COURT.
FROM THE CHICAGO BULLS --
>> THERE WE GO.
>> DeMAR DeROZAN.
FROM THE ATLANTA HAWKS, TREY
YOUNG.
THOSE ARE YOUR EAST BACK COURT
STARTERS.
DeROZAN, WHAT A SEASON FOR THE
30 AND 17 BULLS.
HIS FIRST ALL-STAR SELECTION
SINCE '18.
HIS FIFTH OVERALL.
26, 5 AND 5, SHOOTING 50%.
12 GAMES OF AT LEAST 30 POINTS
FOR DeMAR DeROZAN AND THE TEAM
THAT IS NUMBER TWO BEHIND MIAMI.
AND TREY YOUNG, HIS FOURTH
SEASON.
HIS SECOND ALL-STAR SELECTION.
28 POINT A GAME.
NUMBER FIVE.
NINE ASSISTS, NUMBER THREE.
FRY% FROM THE FLOOR.
38% FROM DEEP.
AND THE LAEMT HAWKS, TREY YOUNG
IS AN ALL-STAR STARTER.
>> I LIKE TREY A LOT.
I THOUGHT IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
ZACH LA VINE.
NO DISRESPECT.
THE LAUKS THE 12th SEED.
LaVINE.
I'M NOT TRYING TO HATE ON TREY
BUT THAT'S MY OPINION.
>> I THINK BOTH OF THEM, EVEN
ONE WOULD MAKE IT.
IF TREY YOUNG WASN'T THERE.
>> THE WAY THE PROCESS IS IS WHO
THE FANS WANT.
>> IN TERMS OF FAN VOTING, TREY
YOUNG IS WHAT THE FANS WANT TO
SEE.
>> I'M JUST PROUD OF MY BOY, MY
BOY MARK WORKS WITH THE BULLS.
I CAN'T EVEN PRONOUNCE IT BUT
THEY'VE DONE A FABULOUS JOB.
I SAID BEFORE THE SEASON, THE
CHICAGO BULLS ARE MY SURPRISE
TEAM.
MAN, THEY CAN'T GET A BREAK WITH
THE INJURIES.
THE INJURIES BUG HAS KILLED
THEM.
THEY STILL GOT THE SECOND BEST
RECORD IN THE EASTERN
CONFERENCE.
SHOUT OUT TO THE BULLS FOR
PUTTING A GREAT TEAM TOGETHER.
AT SOME POINT, THEY'LL BE
HEALTHY.
>> INSIDE THE NBA, YOU'LL HAVE
TIME TO FORMULATE WHO YOU THINK
THE RESERVES WILL BE.
>> YES?
>> PHOENIX SUNS.
NO STARTERS?
BEST RECORD IN THE NBA.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT HAPPENED WITH THE UTAH JAZZ,
TOO.
>> DEVIN BOOKER IS PLAYING
GREAT.
>> I'VE GOT A QUESTION F